welcome back to rockstars i'm eric voss
in the batman movie starring robert
pattinson as a younger bruce wayne
directed by matt reeves is set to
redefine the brand at this weekend's dc
fandom with major updates about the
mysterious plot the villain
and whether pattinson's take on the dark
knight leans more toward team edward
or team 19th century lighthouse keeper
goddamn
fox
with more and more updates coming out
about this film i think we can actually
piece together what the story might look
like when it comes out on its new
release date of october 1st 2021
boiler warning in case you don't want to
know
okay chill out okay ahead of updates
from dc's august fandom panel
reports from the movie screenwriter matt
tomlin promised that matt reeve's vision
for this film will quote blow
everyone away that's some high praise
from the
guy who also had hand in crafting this
vision and the plot but hey it's nice
when showbiz types like working together
right
earlier this year reeves released some
early test footage and imagery showing
robert pattinson in the bat suit and the
cow with an interesting chest emblem
that looks like it could be
detachable weapons like retractable
blades with
sharpened edges and handles that look
like they could be the split handle of a
handgun
and yes i took the time to construct
these to prove how they would work
stop judging me in that early test
footage we heard composer michael
giacchino's new completed batman score
that he made for this film sounds
awesome reeves also released fuller
images of pattinson batman with his new
batmobile
a muscle car with an exposed back engine
and then there were some leaked set
photos and videos showing stunt
performer stand-ins for batman
with a bulkier padded stunt version of
the bat suit
and we think selena kyle with batman
riding this movie's
bat cycle here you can see his bat suit
in daylight he's wearing
gauntlets with quill-like projectiles
and perhaps nozzles for those visible
under the wrists now they were shooting
this scene at a cemetery in glasgow
scotland and reports have suggested that
the movie will resume production in the
uk in a matter of days
so it's not clear how much the movie
they've shot but zoe kravitz has
indicated that she has
suited up in the catwoman suit after
michelle pfeiffer's iconic stylized
stitched together cat suit for
tim burton's batman returns and anne
hathaway's more functional goggles
turned kitty headband and christopher
nolan's the dark knight rises
goggles that would have had zero
peripheral vision fans are hoping that
kravitz's costume will have a hint of
the purple from
catwoman's look in the long halloween
the comic storyline this movie is said
to be inspired from
a good amount of indoor scenes have also
been shot based on another
leaked set photo spoiler warning the
studio definitely didn't want people to
see this though i would say it brings up
more questions and answers
a mystery character with this head
wrapped in tape or cellophane
a spike driven through the head and
written over it no
more lies so along with kravitz as
selena kyle paul dana will be playing
edward nashton this movie's riddler
colin farrell is playing oswald
cobblepot the penguin john tuturo as
gotham crime boss carmine falcone
jeffrey wright as jim gordon perhaps
also the front man for a gotham central
series hbo is developing which is set in
this universe
peter sarsgaard as district attorney gil
coulson and jamie lawson as mayoral
candidate
bella real elliot warren also indicated
he was joining the cast some believe he
could be playing
the batman villain firefly and of course
andy circus is playing alfred pennyworth
and he indicated this movie's story will
be
more bruce and alfred focused now reeves
has also said that the story won't be a
year
one batman story this is the batman
who's been around the block before
thus has already assembled suit and when
it comes to his experience level please
ignore his bike handling skills and that
matt reeves wants this year 2 batman
story to evoke classic noir mysteries
like
chinatown with all of this i think we
have a pretty good idea of what this
plot might actually look like
and how it could set up the sequels that
this reeves batman movie is expected to
have
but before we continue thanks to bang
energy for sponsoring this video
every can of bang is 16 ounces it
contains 300 milligrams of caffeine it's
sugar-free and has
zero calories yet it tastes great
there's over 20 different flavors to
choose from one of those flavors is
black cherry vanilla
my favorite flavor if you love cherry if
you love vanilla and you have a darkness
inside your soul
this is the drink for you because it'll
totally energize that emo side of you
check out bang on instagram you can get
25 off your order when you go to bang
energy.com and use the code new
rockstars25
there you can buy cans of bang energy
including their sweet tea and keto
coffee flavors you can also get clothing
fitness supplements all kinds of stuff
to be your best
bang self thanks again to bang energy
for sponsoring this video get 25
off at bang energy.com using the code
newrockstars25
okay so i actually think the movie is
gonna open with tapehead this will be
the horrific crime scene that the
world's greatest detective has to
investigate in past videos i've
speculated that the taped up head could
be
the calling card of a batman villain
like hush or maybe even
professor pig but that no more lies
inscription is
obviously the big mystery here the
enigma that'll keep that man tugging at
the cord
until he arrives at the dark dark truth
i think what we're looking at here folks
is
a riddle left by the man who committed
this crime
edward nashton does that make him the
villain well not so fast because what's
his motive
no more lies suggests we're looking at a
victim expected to be honest and
trustworthy in his career
but someone whose lies have devastating
consequences
like a media figure or a political
leader
reports have suggested that there will
be a subplot surrounding a mayoral
campaign
and i think the victim here is the man
whose death triggered that special
election
the corrupt ex-mayor of gotham city
running to replace them
will be bella rayoff but she needs an
opponent someone to represent the gotham
establishment a wealthy gothamite with a
history of running for
mayor of gotham oswald cobblepot now
batman's investigation will unravel
how the previous mayor's murder
intertwines with the ongoing interests
of gotham's elite
represented by cobblepot and others like
carmine falcone
nashton could be a kind of whistleblower
who kills off these elites one by one i
mean riddles behind hoping someone will
expose the true conspiracy
a shadowy cabal of power players
actually running the city for centuries
known as the court of owls now some of
you may be scratching your head thinking
oh here comes boss with this weird bird
obsession
true i do love birds or absurd feather
clowns who defy gravity and [ __ ] eggs
but
comic readers recognize the court of
owls as the dark cult we have been
wanting to see in a movie for years
and with selena kyle joining batman in
this investigation i think among the
dark enterprises of the court of owls
is human trafficking sexual slavery
creepy parties you know
epstein [ __ ] this will be celina's
crusade that she's fighting against and
she and batman will need
each other's resources and connections
following the breadcrumb trail of
riddles left behind by an ashton
from crime scenes maybe to other defaced
corpses
to blow this conspiracy wide open topple
cobble
and set up a sequel where batman will
confront the court of owls more directly
among the set photos in the glasgow area
was a billboard reading
gotham renewal corporation investing in
our future gotham orphanage
i'm sorry to keep calling this out but
it's super weird to advertise
hey we got kids with no parents over
here and the weirdness of that makes me
believe that this could be a
front by the court of owls a seemingly
philanthropic effort to support
cobblepot's campaign but really an
insidious cover
for a child human trafficking operation
that
along with casting reports looking for
circus performers
could be how this movie could end with
bruce meeting
teenage orphan richard grayson rescued
from a hopefully liberated gotham orphan
system
and set up to join a crime-fighting
partnership
who makes certain no child of gotham is
ever
left in the dark we're in the middle of
dc week here at new rockstars and we
will be covering all the big reveals
from dc fandom
join this nerdy discussion though on our
discord server by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars follow me on
instagram at eavos follow new rockstars
subscribe and be sure to hit that
notification bell so you know right when
our deep dives into the new footage from
the batman come
out not be just sitting around holed up
in your own farts
[Music]
you